[inaudible].
All right, people. This is the
Big Bananas, bonkers Rubin Report,
end of the year clip show recapping some
of my favorite moments at 2018 before
we hit the clips though,
I want to take a quick moment to thank
all of you guys who listen, watch, share,
and support the show.
You guys are the engine that have kept
us totally independent for over two years
now and trust me, we're just getting
started. 2018 was by far our biggest year,
yet as the intellectual
dark web went mainstream.
I toured over 80 cities all over
the world that Jordan Peterson.
I also returned to stand up comedy,
check the link down below for upcoming
dates and we continued to have the
conversations that I believe can
restore some sanity to the universe.
I've actually never felt better about
the direction we're headed and with your
help, we'll continue to grow. So
here's my one sentence. Sell job.
Help us remain totally independent
and fan funded by going to Dave
rubin.com/donate. All right,
that's it. Now more importantly,
thank you and enjoy some of my favorite
moments with some of my favorite people
from 2018 but you were on with Kathy
Newman on it's Canada channel for UK,
UK Channel Four, sorry, four.
Yup. And there there is,
I mean everyone that's watching this
has probably seen this already have,
you should go watch it yet if you
haven't, you should go watch it. But,
but in effect,
basically she tried to make an argument
that you have heard a good Julian Times
before,
but why does your right to free speech
supersede a trans person's right to feel
okay with themselves are saying even
the way she phrased the question was a
little confused and conflated,
but well the thing,
but the reaction to it w w your,
your answer was great,
but it was the reaction the regular
people watching at home. Then we're going,
this is nonsense. This is just abject. No.
The only thing that's really made it viral
is the fact that she recognized it in
the moment and what she was
saying [inaudible] where
you could see the light go
on briefly and she just went,
wait, what did I just say? Yeah,
and there was no escape. It was, yeah,
it was pretty. It was pretty grand. Yeah.
Well the funny thing about her argument
is that it's Pr was predicated on the
idea that somehow people have
a right to be comfortable.
It's like that's just not a right you
have in life all the things you can say
that you don't have a right to in life.
Being comfortable is number one,
which you made that point. Yeah,
you can offend me right now.
So the thing is is if you,
if you're right to be comfortable
trumps my right to talk,
then I don't get to talk ever
because I'm going to say things.
If I'm actually talking, I'm
going to say things. If they're,
if they're profound things, if they're
contentious, things are truthful things,
I'm going to say things that if they don't
disturb you are going to disturb you.
And if they don't disturb you,
there's someone that's going
to be disturbed about them.
So what's the answer to that? Everyone
can be comfortable in the silence,
but that doesn't also doesn't work because
then we can't exchange ideas were not
comfortable in the silence.
We're isolated and Dan didn't the silence.
So it's a completely
incoherent perspective.
I will say the last time
I was on your program,
the only time I was on before I remember
you asking me what I thought of the
left and I quipped
uh, what left? I haven't seen
him in. Who knows how long. Yeah.
That turns out not to have been
right. They, they exist. I mean, yes,
I hadn't seen them.
But one of the funny things about my
trajectory is that having been, you know,
the experience was very much like
being ejected from the left. Yeah.
And I got ejected from the left and a
lot of people on the right embraced me,
which was weird.
And then even weirder was the discovery
of all the other people who had been
ejected from the left. And so the point
is, this is sort of a cryptic left,
you're talking to the
right. Exactly. Well and so,
so the point is the discovery that
there are a lot of people who you might,
if you just looked them up online you
would come to the wrong conclusion about
where their sympathies lay
that that's interesting.
And I think the conversation between
those of us who have been, you know,
catapulted out and those of us who have
landed on the right is going to involve
the recognition that in fact we are all
suffering from a kind of political PTSD
and that in fact many people who are on
the right are there because they've been
traumatized by really low quality,
dangerous leftist thinking.
Um,
but that that does not make their
right of center position natural.
I'm not saying there are no
natural positions over there,
but many people who are there are there
because they have run from things that
they've heard on the left.
And once we give up on the idea that
anybody on the map today has the answer
with respect to the policies that we
are supposed to embrace once we say
actually everybody's policies are
a failure. If we were to enact uh,
the libertarian program,
it would fail for game theoretic reasons.
If we were to enact the socialist program,
it would fail for game theoretic reason.
Same thing, right? So the point is, okay,
fresh sheet of paper
with respect to policy.
Now there's a lot for us to talk about
starting from values and there are a lot
of people who if you ask them to list
their values apart from policy would fall
out on the left. So, um, wow.
Is it an interesting moment that that
conversation may be about to get started
and to be in a position
to actually influence it,
I must say is a pretty exciting one of
the things that I found out that was sort
of amazing about your history,
you,
you briefly mentioned your right
before we started, you were a Marxist
time in your life. Most people will find
this hard to believe, but it is true,
but it's not that unusual.
Uh,
most of the leading conservative
thinkers of our time time, uh,
did not start off as conservator.
You've got a couple like a Bill
Buckley and the George will,
but I'm in Milton Friedman was, it was,
it was a liberal and a Keynesian, uh,
high Eq was a socialist. Ronald
Reagan was so far left at one point,
the FBI was following him,
you know, uh, so, uh, the,
there's a huge movement, uh, from the left
to the right as people get older. Yeah.
I'm, I'm well aware, as I mentioned to
you earlier, as a former progressive,
I understand that that
movement in the modern sense.
Do you remember sort of
what you were thinking,
what appealed to you at that
time about Marxism? Yes. I mean,
there was no alternative being discussed.
Um,
my first job was as a Western
Union Messenger and a,
I would come home on some nights.
I would take the fifth avenue bus,
which cost all of 15 cents in those days.
But I figured I'd splurge now and then,
and I would drive. It would go
all the way up, Fifth Avenue,
pass all these lord and Taylor
and all these fancy places.
And then we were across 57th street pass,
Carnegie Hall and down Riverside Drive.
And that was the sort of the
Gold Coast area. And then yes,
I came across this long viaduct and
that turned into 130 fifth street.
Suddenly there were the tenements
and I went, why is this?
I mean, it's so, so it's so different and,
and nothing in the schools
or most of the books, uh,
seem to deal with that and walks,
dealt with that. Uh, so it's, it's,
it's like winning an election when
there's only one person running.
So then what was your wake up to?
What was wrong with that
line of thinking a fact?
I'm not one of those who thinks things
are worse now than they've ever been.
I mean, this is a country where we've, we
fought over a big issue for a long time.
The revolutionary war of course. And
then of course, we had the war of 1812.
We had the civil war, World
War One, World War II, Vietnam,
Korean War, nine 11 people hated Ronald
Reagan. Thought he was a warmonger.
Uh, George Bush. Uh, what was
it? Bush lie, people died. Uh,
there's tension in this country.
There always has been a,
for a very long period of time. We get
along better now than ever before. We've,
I said,
man,
I don't think you can understate the fact
that we elected and reelected a black
president in the 50s.
The polls show that the percentage of
white Americans who will be willing to
vote for a black person, no matter
how well I call it for qualified,
was in the single digits.
Uh,
and now I think only three
or 4% of Republicans and
Democrats say that under no
circumstances would they vote for a
black person, for president. In fact,
if greater prejudice against
the Mormon, uh, and again,
warning for a woman than it is voting
for a black person now. So, uh,
America is a very different
place than it used to be.
And for the left to act like it's not
insults the men and women who worked hard
to get us to where we are right now.
It's actually really
true to say that Obama was basically as
honest as a politician can be and still
be a politician. I mean, I think you have,
I'm sure he lied about things, right?
Yeah.
But there's no story on Obama being
just this depraved person behind closed
doors who get, who's
a, who's a con artist,
who gets away with everything that he
can get away with a WHO's trailing along
list of key business and
interpersonal casualties.
Who will tell you if you put them on
camera or you can't get them privately?
He's the worst person they've ever met.
Right? That's his president now. Right.
It's just that it's a completely
different personality. Um,
and uh, I think that, I
think so whatever happens,
let's say good that let,
let's say we're living in
a universe where having a,
a uniquely narcissistic,
selfish,
shallow personality in this
position of power works out.
Well,
let's just say that I mean a lot.
So let's just take your wrecking ball
theory. He's kind of swung through here.
He's disrupted everything. You
know? I do view him, as I said,
I've said before as a kind of
evil Chauncey Gardner character.
I don't view him as this sort of mastery.
I think Scott Adams is
completely out to lunch on this.
I don't think he's this genius
manipulator. I mean, he's got,
he's got some talents obviously,
but I think it's much less
calculated bolus calculator.
I don't think him contradicting himself.
Two sentences later, right when he says,
you know this amazing letter,
you'd all like to read this letter
and then he says two sentences later,
I haven't read the letter. That's
not calculated. He's just not,
doesn't have the car.
He can't take the cognitive overhead
to even figure out what you know,
what was logically implied by the
last thing you said? Right? So He's,
the truth is he's not,
he lies all the time,
but worse than line.
And this is the great distinction that
philosopher Harry Frankfurt made in his
book on Bullshit. Worse than line is
that he's bullshitting all the time.
And the difference between
line and bullshitting is it.
If I'm going to lie to you,
I'm paying attention to what I know.
Right.
I know what is true.
I know you know what is true and I'm
trying to insert ally into the space
provided in a way that you won't notice.
Right?
Like I'm having to keep track of reality
in order to lie to you successfully.
I understand your logical expectations.
I understand that.
If I tell you that,
you know,
I was an hour late here
because the traffic was so bad.
I can't say in the next sentence. Oh, I
left an hour late from my house. Right.
So like so, um, uh, so the bullshit
or isn't doing any of that,
that bullshit or is just talking right
and therefore has renounced the reality
testing he has to do to lie
successfully and he's just,
he has the burden is not on him to make
any sense at all in the end. And um,
that to an amazing degree,
not entirely.
I think he does actually lie strategically
sometimes, but to an amazing degree.
And this is what I think is so
harmful about his presidency.
Whatever happens with North Korea or
anything else that we might care about to
an amazing degree.
He has revealed that half of our
society will accept somebody who is just
bullshitting all the time about
things. Great and small. I mean,
it doesn't matter how important
or how inconsequential
porn stars, you know, what,
you know,
what just happened with the g seven,
you know what was said behind closed
doors, what he's going to say to,
to a you some maniac with, with nukes. Um,
there's just a,
we've
completely forsaken any expectation of
a reality based conversation and many
people seem to revel in it.
Many people seem to think this is just,
this is just good fun. This is
like, this is, you know, the answer.
It's a bit of the wrecking ball theory.
Gone to some nihilistic extreme where
it's just, let's just, you know,
let's just burn it all out.
Having gone through the looking glass,
having gone through the direct, you know,
to borrow a phrase from the far left,
but the lived experience of actually
being at the center of a mob at the center
of riots and then watching as the world,
the mainstream media and others tried
to do a public relations spin on it and
tell a totally different story to live
that and to watch the institution that
you love to become totally disloyal to
you and to watch many people whom you
respected, um, hide.
Yeah,
you can't unsee that.
It's valuable.
And the fact that we're sitting here
talking together and that many of us in,
you know, the intellectual dark web
and, and this and this bigger group are,
are speaking and saying actually the
culture of fear that is society wide is
real.
And so I'll say the first time I
met my students after the November,
2016 election after Trump was elected,
evergreen is a very left place.
Olympia is a very left place.
Pretty much everyone on
campus had that glazed eyes.
Slack Jawed look that people in most
progressive enclaves will be familiar with
from that time, from those few
days, right. Myself included,
even though, you know,
I was no Hillary fan,
but I didn't see that outcome coming and
I certainly didn't vote for Trump. I, um,
we got to class and my co faculty
whom I admire greatly, uh,
just proceeded with her lecture on horse
evolution and I'm looking around the
classroom going,
no one here cares about horses.
There is not the day.
Um,
so she ended up at early and we had lab
a couple of hours later and before she
let them go, I said, hold on, if anyone
wants to stay, this is no longer class,
but if anyone wants to stay,
I would be happy to lead a
conversation about what just happened,
what just happened to our country.
And about 40 of our 50 students
stayed and skip their lunch hour.
And we went right to anatomy lab that
afternoon from, from this conversation.
And what I said to them was,
do not for a minute believe that
racists and sexist elected Trump.
Think about how many times you have had
to censor yourself on this campus when
you had an opinion that was even slightly
different from the accepted dogma.
And that conversation not
only brought life to the room,
but afterwards I had several
students come up to me,
some of them in tears
telling me stories about,
one of them had lost a job on campus
for speaking and opinion that was not
accepted. One of them had an, another
story of another friend who lost a job.
Others talked about their
self censorship and um,
that and all of these people, again,
we're far left, not that it should matter,
but these weren't even people who are
conservatives or who held conservative
views.
So that,
that is the larger culture of fear
that is hardly restricted to evergreen.
But as society wide that we're,
that we're speaking about and the people
are responding to because in you at
Google,
at Starbucks and in cubicles in campuses
but far be on campuses across the
country and across the weird country
is at least this is a problem.
Shapiro, will you bake Ruben a
wedding cake? Huh? Okay. So, I mean,
my answer is I'm married already,
right. But an anniversary,
it's my anniversary last
week and anniversary cake
would have been nice. Right.
So I,
so the answer is no,
and the reason I won't is because
it's a religious Jew. I, yeah.
I do not participate in activities
that I believe are sinful. But again,
we live in a free country
and Dave knows this.
He doesn't have to care
what I think about sin and,
and as long as I'm not bothering Dave,
I don't see why it's a problem. Yeah.
So it will, I will. I did. Does Dave
have a husband? Yeah. I mean like, okay.
And Are we friends?
Yeah.
And Are we going to go out to dinner
sometime in the near future? Yeah, but,
but there's a difference between me just
being friends with Dave and me actively
participating in an event that
I feel is religiously sinful.
And I think that is how most religious
Christians in most religious Jews feel.
And while that's awkward, yeah,
we're still friends in spite of it,
which is why we're friends.
If your friends in spite of it,
then there'll be a bad thing. We'll look
when I, when I did your interview show,
which by the way, I mean, yeah, you Jack,
the idea of an enter your show front
of me. It's all right. It's true.
But nobody had done it before me.
But what you said that to me in,
and I truly mean this, like if you
think what I'm doing is sinful, like I,
I know it sounds Glib,
but I don't care. I,
and this is my view is you don't have
to can right. Free Country, right?
Like that's the thing and it's
like, look, look, there is,
of course someone's going to go,
well wait a minute.
If you really think his marriage is
simpler saying of course they'll,
they'll may be a place that in the nature
of our friendship maybe that we can't
quite get to,
that I would be able to get to with
someone that didn't think for sure.
That is very possible. And, and it,
and it goes both ways, right? Like,
I then look at you and I go,
well [inaudible] you don't
want me teaching your kid
about the nature of family
perhaps, right? I mean like,
like there are some believers,
but you're probably a pretty good dad.
Like you know what I mean? Like what,
why is it that we're able to do this?
And most people can't do this.
That's what I'm curious to go home at
night and we can have our own lives.
I mean that's,
that's a real,
and I think part of friendship by the
way is that like we go home at night and
we just have our own lives. Yeah.
I'm not married to you. Right?
Like that's like my wife and I
have to agree on these issues.
You and I don't have to agree on these
issues in order for us to share our
common space together.
And that's really the important thing.
Your wife and you have to agree on these,
on all of these issues or just the, the,
the sort of, the more foundational
and the foundational ones.
But I do think that you know how you raise
your kids religiously and with regard
things like sexual morality does
actually have to be at the root of,
of how you teach your kids.
Yeah. So if you have deep,
if you have deep divisions with your
spouse on these issues, I think that,
and you're looking to build
a family anyway. Yeah.
Then I think that these are issues where
building on a bad foundation is a bad
move. So let me, okay, so if you
wouldn't bake me a cake, that's okay.
And now because it's 50, 50, I
can't bake you a cake, which I,
David's measurable chef and he would've
done it coaching the whole wow man. Yeah.
No, I feel bad. You would have done
it for you. You got me this clothes.
Putting that aside, you can't have
any of it's kosher cake now. Um,
if we were having an anniversary party,
would you come?
If I was inviting all the crew that we
all know and we were just an anniversary
party,
we're just having a party and a,
and I'll even throw in some kosher food
for you to make sure you don't have to
bring your own. Honestly,
I'd have to think about it.
I'd have to think about it in the same
way. So That's interesting to me. Yeah,
that's a different thing. Well,
not really, because again,
it's if you're a religious person,
and again,
take it from the religious perspective,
from the religious perspective,
the question is, are you glorifying
something that you think is sinful? Yeah.
So is it a party for something that
you think was originally sinful?
Can you participate in that?
So from a religious point of view,
that's an actual serious moral question.
Yeah. When I go out to dinner with you,
the answer is yes, right?
Because that's not actually like,
let's celebrate something that I
feel that you're doing is sinful.
But I'd have to, I'd have to
think about that one. I'm,
and I'm being in a perfectly straight
forward as possible. I want you to.
So it's the,
see that's so interesting to me cause
it's like if I threw a regular party,
just we were just going a party at my
house and all the guys [inaudible] like I
bake you a cake that had nothing
to do with the gay wedding. Right.
And that would go to a party with you.
That has nothing to do with gay marriage,
which will make me a regular cake. Could
I just have a Thursday? Sure. I'd give you
my baking socks.
I'll just buy you one [inaudible] Shapiro
cake and then I'm going to write it.
Then once I get it here, I can just
have a broader base of crap. I mean,
it's not gonna be good, but
it's, but it'll be there.
Silicon Valley at this point has
a bit of a conformity problem.
It has a bit of a way in which
people are, you know, too, too much,
all thinking the same way. It's just like
the, there was, you know, the, the apple,
I saw this,
this meme on the Internet the other day,
where was sort of the
silicon valley in 1997,
Colin think different than Silicon Valley,
2018 colon think the same.
It's like you want to ask the question,
why is it, why is it so, so way?
I think these things are, are, you know,
they're, they're somewhat over determined.
So I would say a part of
it is, um, is that, uh,
it's probably the most educated part of
the country in terms of how much time
people spent in college.
And I think one of the downsides of too
much education is that you get the most
brainwashed. And so it's, it's, it's the
most educated can also mean that it is,
it is the, it is the most
brainwashed. This is probably
also true of the founders,
but certainly of, um, of many of the
rank and file people who are, um,
you know, if you're sort of like a
really good engineer or, um, you know,
really good at some specific thing,
um,
your education typically does not
involve you thinking that much about,
about politics. And so, uh,
it's not necessarily from
deep ideological conviction.
It's often more as a fashion statement
than as a question of, of power. So, uh,
and so one of the things that's always
a little bit hard to score is that even
if you took a survey and silicon valley,
it's, it's, it comes out as, you know,
quite far to the left,
you know, weirdly, um,
uniform weird sort of group think.
It's a super hard to know where
the people really believe this,
whether they're with, they're
just going along. And so I,
I think it's pretty liberal, but, um,
but of course not as liberal as it looks.
And that's, that's in a way worse because
it means people are too scared to,
to articulate things. I think
diversity's a good thing. I think,
especially in a diversity of
ideas is, is, is, is to be valued,
but you don't have real diversity when
you just have a group of people who look
different and, uh, and think alike.
And so it's, it's, it has to meet,
it has to be more than just,
uh, you know, than just, um,
having the extras from the space cantina
scene or something like that. Right. And,
uh, and that's, and so
that's always, that's always,
so it's always like an internal critique,
the diversity methods that it's not
about diversity at all. It's about,
it's about a conformity.
But the point is we're going to have
to live with each other as a nation and
we're going to have to love each other.
And there are a lot of people with
this mimetic complex in their mind.
This is why I went and I talked to Kanye.
I thought what Kanye was gonna do was
de Trump a Phi Magda with people who
wanted their towns in Ohio and western
Pennsylvania to start working again.
People who, uh, you know,
we're drinking themselves silly feeling
that they were part of the American
dream.
And got sidelined,
we are going to have to find common cause
and it's just not that hard. You know,
it's just not that hard to have a friend
who's Hugh is different than yours is
not that hard to have a friend.
You and I have serious political
differences at this point.
It just doesn't cause me
to want to silence you.
And so my claim is is that even though
they're aligned and even though they know
they're lie,
you've got to experiment with love and
forgiveness to the best of your ability.
And I can't tell you
that I never lashed out.
I think I lashed out a little bit at
Rebecca Lewis because she was lying.
She said it will never not be funny
that the entire intellectual dark web is
only located on Youtube.
Oh really?
So the 12 rules of life isn't a book that
exists and the waking up podcast isn't
something that has no video.
Even if it exists on Youtube,
people listen to it off of youtube is
that it's not true that we don't have any
events. Of course Rebecca
Lewis is lying. She knows.
She's like data and society is lie. These
people all know that there are a lie,
but they think that they're lying for
some beautiful reason to keep our country
together, to make sure that we're
not in the hands of a tyrant,
to make sure that every child has
a shot at a beautiful tomorrow.
And I'm sorry that they're this confused,
but have some compassion because
they don't have the compassion.
When we hear about empathy,
okay, the onus is on us.
They don't have this great
empathy. They like, I,
I still care about trans people that
I can't care about white people. Okay,
that gives me a headache.
You're either empathic and you care
about people in general. Yeah. Or your,
it's selective empathy and you really
have a lot of hate in your soul.
So I set it Goddamn example
that that's my basic take,
which is you've got to love the people
who are allying thinking that they're
advancing the world's cause and you
have to love them out of their cult.
And if we're not willing to take that on,
then I don't know what we're doing.
But I can't always make this this
high bar that I'm setting for myself.
I will fail. I would lash out at somebody
but have a forgiveness narrative.
There is in general, no redemptive
redemption narrative on the left.
That's why it's not even a religion.
People say it's a cult.
It's religion without a redemption
narrative. There's nothing.
If what you're really excited
about the sticking it to the man,
whoever the man is,
you're not fundamentally a good person.
You're a person who's working through
your own personal anger and so my claim is
is that
love the people who are lying against
you and figure out what an incredible
power, incredibly powerful weapon that
is. Because at the end of the day,
after you knock them
senseless to the pavement,
you better offer them a hand up
and say, look, it wasn't personal.
It's just you were, you were
threatening our system and you know,
I felt like I couldn't communicate to
you while you were still in the call.
That's where I am.
Well,
there is a fear that if you acknowledge
that there are differences between
individuals or groups that you're
saying that one group is inferior.
So there's been a co they,
the idea that we have to be the same to
be equal has been a very prevalent and
strong idea. I don't know who
came where the idea comes from,
but it's, it's, um,
it's dangerous because if you,
um,
if you argue that no true
or quality can be achieved,
unless we're all the same, then no,
then we can't have a quality. However,
if you argue that no,
we are all morally equal and that
we deserve equal opportunity and,
uh, the equal, um, uh,
w we deserve equal opportunities to
live a happy, flourishing life. However,
there are differences between us.
Yeah. Then you can preserve that, um,
ethical principle.
So it's very problematic for people
who think that there can be no equality
between men and women unless we are
proven to be the same identical,
um, because the evidence doesn't
support this. The idea that we're
the same. Well, look, I've had
so many years doing this, Dave,
and I can't explain how I still love it.
I love the interplay.
You should love what you do.
Know why you learn something every day,
every day you learn.
So I can't be close minded
like I'm a liberal politically,
certainly in social issues,
but I'm not close minded enough to think
that you can't have an opposing view.
I like the argument. I liked the
discussion, but in interviewing, I never,
I mean my ego at the door,
I try not to use the word I to irrelevant
and I tried to get into what any
other, you know, Edward Bennett Williams,
the great lawyer told me once, I said,
what is the role of the
criminal defense lawyer?
He said to get one person on the
jury to walk in your client's shoes.
If you can get one person to walk in
your client's shoes, got a hung jury.
All he has to do is say,
I would've done that.
I've been in spaces at
Columbia for example,
or conversations where my being black.
It was obvious to me that
there is an assumption of,
of moral worthiness or have a kind of
heightened moral knowledge that I would
have as a black person that
a white person wouldn't have.
And you know,
I think,
I think I'm not the first to
make this analogy of course,
but the real religious analogy and the
analogy to original sin is pretty apt.
Um, because it, I mean the,
the way this has a lot to do with
black history also because the way I,
the way I see it,
they're kind of two ways to study history.
There's the conventional way, which
is, you know, you study World War One,
you study the causes and consequences
read different takes on, on,
on the significance. And once
you've studied all you need to know,
you move onto the next topic.
But then there's a religious way of
studying history, which is, I mean,
it's not enough to know the facts. We
have to go somewhere on Sunday, every,
you know,
every single week and learn,
talk about the same stories over and
over again. So this is, you know, it's,
it's the difference between how an
atheist learns about the life of Jesus and
how a Christian learns about the life
of Jesus Jesus and relearn it every week
for the rest of their life.
In my view,
how we're looking at the history
of race relations in this country,
the history of racism,
we are more and more putting it in the
religious category of history of where,
you know,
I can read a piece about the history of
lynching in the New York Times almost
once every two or three months.
Right.
And lemon lynching is a decades old
crime at this point. And Abi, I mean,
Jesus, Great. Obviously it was a heinous
staying on on this country's legacy,
you know,
but then the number of deaths that that
is is the highest amount quoted in New
York Times with regard to how many black
people were lynched in this country is
around 4,000 right?
Every single year.
Twice that many black people
die of homicide. And I,
you just don't even hear about that.
In the New York Times.
There are 20,000 engineers,
engineers making between two and
$400,000 working right now just on Google
search,
just on that one feature of Google
20,000 this is the most technologically
advanced and powerful organization
in the history of the world.
It's technology and capabilities so
far outstrip those to the Pentagon for
example,
where the Chinese military or the Russian,
the Russians or any other group,
this is the most powerful
technological entity in the world,
which has a choke hold on all
human information in English.
So that is all sort of
all you need to know.
I don't care if Jesus is
in charge of the country,
that's too much power for any
entity to have. And it's a,
it's a threat to the nation state
actually, and it's a threat to all of us.
So yeah,
I think whatever it takes is
what we need to do. Like now,
you know, I'm in his lightened meant
guy. But the thing is, is that we're not,
when I look backwards in
time, you know what, what,
what people like Harrison pinker
attribute to the enlightenment are,
you see as the enlightenment being the
latest flowering of a process that was
indescribably older than that is
exactly right. And then in the end,
in the historical sense, certainly
grounded in the religious traditions, but,
and then from my perspective,
grounded in something that's biological,
that's far deeper than that,
like,
like our true proclivity towards
admiration for competence and reciprocity.